Neil Irwin of the Washington Post
economists had predicted a gain of
70,000 jobs yet we get the report this
week that we lost 17,000 jobs what
happened well the economy slowing it's
not rocket science really it's there's
been a lot of indicators that the US
economy slowed down a lot starting maybe
in december maybe a little before and
january was a continuation of that was a
pretty disappointing result everybody
assumed yeah the economy slowed the job
market slowing but it won't be so awful
and said we got a net loss of jobs in
january but i mean with the with this
slowing of the economy couldn't they
have seen that if not predicting the
loss of 17,000 jobs not to go out and
predict that we're going to gain 70,000
jobs well keep in mind there's a certain
level of job creation that just happens
every month just to keep up with the
growth of the population that number the
different estimates may be around
125,000 jobs a month so even if we had
gained 70,000 jobs that wouldn't have
even been enough to keep up with growth
in the population so that wasn't a
terribly foolish optimistic prediction
and it turns out of course numbers
weaker now keep in mind once in a while
they're there is a kind of looky number
that comes through and and the Labor
Department revises these numbers every
month so it may turn out that that in
January there was a slight gain in the
number of jobs who knows but whether
that's the case or not it's clear the
labor market in the US is weakening
quite a lot now the numbers also include
a jobless rate of four point nine
percent that's down from five percent
how does that happen with a net job loss
numbers well it's it's a little tricky
the two sets of data come from different
surveys so there's one survey that
figures out how many jobs there are in
the country where they ask a lot of
employers how many people you have on
your payroll the other survey is of
households they call up people and ask
does any of the people in your household
have a job or not so sometimes in the
short run these surveys can diverge like
they did last month that said there may
be another thing at work there may be
people dropping out of the labor force
who are saying you know it's tough out
there I don't think I can get a job I'm
not even going to try so those people
don't count as unemployed because
they're not actively seeking work so
both both some weird statistical things
and the
and people dropping out of the labor
force could be a factor we're talking
about jobs and unemployment in January
with economics reporter Neil Irwin of
the Washington Post if you'd like to get
involved in the conversation the number
is 20 27 37 triple zero one four
Republicans 202 737 triple zero to four
Democrats independents 20 to 60 to 80
205 and if you're calling from outside
the US 20 to 60 to 80 184 also if you
called within the last 30 days instead
of calling today send us an email
instead the address is journal @ c span
org what does this say the numbers about
the the unemployment the jobless all of
this what does all of this say about
whether or not we are moving into we're
already in or whether or not the
recession is starting to pick up some
steam well economists can the question
of whether we're in recession is
something that a panel of economists
will decide many months from now it's
it's almost an academic exercise whether
it's recession or not if the economy
only grows say half a percent this year
that's going to feel real painful that's
not going to be a pleasant outcome it
might technically not be a recession but
it's not a good thing the economy loses
half a percent if it shrinks half a
percent that might technically be a
recession but and would also feel bad
but not so much worse than than gaining
half a percent people like to focus on
whether it's a recession or not the
important you know question is how much
is the economy slowing and based on the
data yesterday it looks like a good bit
our first call for Neil Irwin of the
Washington Post comes from Kansas City
Kansas good morning yeah you know I keep
hearing this that people quit looking
for work that's crazy just because they
run out of an employment they're going
to stop looking what the heck is that
that makes no sense and it according to
that I want to add to what that lady
before said about when you run out of
unemployment you're not counted well
that's the reason why they don't want
the tax cuts because what the
unemployment extent extended because
that would raise the unemployment rate
and that would be a big problem for that
that's actually part of why the why the
Bush administration doesn't want to
extend unemployment insurance benefits
as part of the stimulus package
Democrats very much want especially the
Senate want to extend the length of time
that you can get unemployment insurance
benefits if you lose your job the Bush
administration and and many Republicans
think that's a bad idea that might
create incentives for people to coast on
on their unemployment insurance benefits
and perhaps not seek a job as actively
as as they should so that's that's one
of the tensions you're seeing between
the two parties right now next up is
schodack New York on our line for
Democrats go ahead good morning c-span I
morning taking my call the question to
me is this which January are you talking
about we've had what 78 January since
Bush came in office personally myself I
think they've been cooking the books all
along has ever been a tally of the jobs
created versus the jobs lost over the
term of his administration and I believe
that I remember when I was working my
way through college as a as a janitor
one of the jobs Americans don't want the
Carter Administration had the star thing
called cita I believe to get people they
were publicly funded jobs for 12 months
that got people back on the work rolls
and I also believe that corporations use
a lot of temporary workers and those are
tallied into the job gains but they're
really only temporary can you answer
those questions thank you yeah there's
some interesting points there there has
been a net gain in the number of jobs if
you add up all the losses and these
numbers we're talking about our net
numbers so if one company adds jobs and
other cuts them those are added together
and the other subtracted so it's a net
number over the course of the Bush
administration I believe there there was
just barely a positive employment record
for his first term there's been pretty
solid steady gains since then it is the
case that under the Bush administration
job
has been much slower than in the 1990s
there are a lot of different reasons
economists argue over why that might be
the case but these are net numbers and
this number we're talking about today is
from January 2008 the month that just
ended what where are most of the jobs
being lost the worst sectors right now
for job losses or construction which
makes sense because the housing market
is in pretty rough shape and
manufacturing which is a little more
surprising because actually exports are
doing well people are you know American
businesses are exporting more more of
what they make abroad but that's not
been strong enough to create enough of
an up winds to to generate employment
gains in manufacturing in fact
manufacturers are cutting a lot of jobs
part of that may be due to the housing
market you know companies that
manufacture lumber products and stuff
that goes into houses or cutting jobs
because they're cutting back also the
auto industry still having the US auto
industry still having pretty sink own
problems what if anything are in either
one of the stimulus packages either the
one in the house or the one in the
Senate that may turn around the downturn
in the housing market there are some
subtle things in in both bills that
would deal with the the direct impact on
housing there's a proposal to lift the
caps on what these government-sponsored
enterprises called Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac what kind of how big a
mortgages they can buy there are some
things with the Federal Housing
Administration to deal with housing but
most of what these stimulus packages do
is try and put some money into people's
pockets it tries to in the house version
at six hundred dollars Senate it's 500
but to a wider group of people and the
idea is there's there's you know
everybody's worried that consumer
spending is going to slow down but
people will have not have jobs not have
money in their pockets that they will
stop spending money and that'll slow
down the economy the ideas here's a few
dollars go spend it and maybe we'll will
avoid a recession and does the money
have to be spent in order to get the
economy going again we've done this
subject before and a lot of the caller
say if they get some kind of a rebate
from the government they're going to put
it in savings many people do there's a
there's a lot of there's there's a lot
of research on this and it's I would
argue
kind of inconclusive some people take
the money and spend it and then whoever
they spend it to you know if they spend
it to a store that store will reinvest
it and do different things with it so
there's other people who do spend the
money there can be a multiplier effect
but that's certainly true plenty people
take the weather it's three hundred
dollars as it was in 2001 2003 five
hundred dollars 600 dollars and sticking
the bank and and add to their savings
back to the phones Cedartown Georgia
you're on the Washington journal go
ahead yes I appreciate you taking the
call just an observation I don't know if
it's a question or not you know last
century there's a book written where you
just generated manufacturer and just
keep jobs one build ships take them out
and shoot them in the ocean but you know
we've got a war we're spending billions
you know in Iraq I don't totally
disagree with that I think we make a
statement hey they're not going to tread
on America or any other country i think
you know we went in there with all
nations on a wall terrorism or of course
this is you know this war is generating
a lot of jobs in economy for our country
but still i want our boys home and let's
find another way i think we've made the
statement you know you better tread
gently on this country another statement
of the funeral if you know the federal
government has issued great you know
funds to on buying hybrid cars they need
to increase that if you want to see a
change that would be a definite change
increase that and let's get some of
these patents that's been you know you
know and maybe rumor I don't know they
buy up all these carburetors they could
get high efficiency let's get those off
the shelf and let's stop a dependency on
the for know we've got shell all
resources for take us for three thousand
years out west I'm sure it's a whole lot
less than a hundred dollars a barrel but
you know get the federal programs to
increase the hybrid of the three car the
main trip we've talked about all ago
that generates all kinds of jobs you
look the people to build a rocket you
look at Euston controls you look at
there's like the auto industry
you got parts companies all over this
country supporting of the three big car
manufacturers up there thanks cedar 10
given us a lot to work with Neil Irwin
well it's um there's a distinction we
made between government things the
government can do to to stimulate the
economy in the short run and things that
may or may not be good ideas in the long
run and what the Germans talking about
is things that might help with energy
independence and and certainly our
debates that people on the Capitol over
there may they have as time goes on
what's being talked about for for fiscal
stimulus to try and keep the economy
from having a serious downturn this year
are things that can very rapidly get
money into people's pockets and there's
quite an emphasis on getting money into
people and into the pockets of people
who have low to moderate incomes those
are the people who jerilee are point2 if
you get a 500 other check if you're if
you're just getting by you're more
likely to spend that money and let it
flow through the economy and then
someone who's more fluent so that's the
kind of measures people are talking
about right now on in Congress to deal
with the downturn next up is Grand Blanc
Michigan good morning thank you very
much for c-span the band-aid approach to
stimulate the economy by getting money
into the hands of the people is just
that just a band-aid approach what needs
to be done is eliminate the income tax
Institute a sales tax and don't tax
entrepreneurship people that work hard
save their money are being taxed at
every level if they would do that that
would free up all the offshore money
would come back into this country
trillions of dollars and this is the
kind of long-term approach that should
be taken on trying to stimulate the
economy don't kill entrepreneurship
another thing that could be done would
be to remove the cap off from Social
Security the Social Security tax is one
of the most unfair taxes that you can
have it if you make below ninety seven
thousand dollars you have to pay the
full amount
you make anything over ninety seven
thousand dollars your tax-free if that
is an unfair I don't know what is thanks
for your call the caller's write about
social security there a lot of people
who argue the way the social security
taxes structured is regressive that it
is is harder on people with low to
middle incomes than those with very high
incomes because you don't on earnings
over yeah I believe he's right 97,000
you you don't pay that social security
tax which is which is pretty substantial
on the on the question of moving away
from an income tax that's of course Mike
Huckabee has gotten some traction on
arguing just that in his presidential
campaign it's an intriguing idea and
people are talking about it it's it's
it's hard to figure out how to execute
it in practice you would there would be
big problems with with potential tax
evasion people trying to avoid paying
that that much higher sales tax but it's
an idea that's out there next up is
Leesburg Virginia good morning boring
yeah I have a major problem it seems
like the last two downturns the economy
have been created by the financial
institutes the banking institutions by
just going crazy with the way they land
and I don't understand why that's
happened but in this case because all
the money was loaned by one organization
and was passed on to another I don't
understand why more emphasis isn't put
on having the people who hold the loans
just understand that they now have a bad
loan in her hands and that the best
thing they can do is to take a deep
breath and say let's uh let's give this
a little more time let's hold the
interest a little longer and let's let
the normal marketplace work its way out
that's number one so I think that's what
happens that's how we get into these
messes and then secondly I really think
our media is out of control in this
country and that they take any little
bit of negative news that has to do with
the economy and they make it because the
20 or 24 hour nature they make it become
bigger and bigger and bigger to the
point where it really freaks people out
and it it's like self-fulfilling and
somewhere online I think the media needs
to take a step back and say you know
we're in this thing together we're all
trying to keep people employed and and
frankly it appears that they really
would rather have people unemployed
by creating a disaster situation by
talking it up and talking up and we have
to be Americans we have to step back
here and say what's the longer picture
we're not in a bad situation right now
but you got you think we were in a huge
situation we come off of many months of
job growth we've come off of male low
interest rates we've come off of
absolutely full employment and you'd
think we were like falling off a cliff
and and it's just a small correction and
if everybody just think about as a
correction rather than go into panic
mode we'd all be a lot of love it all
well I can't speak for for all of the
financial media but I know what what we
do it at the Washington Post is try and
look at the numbers and look at what's
happening with the underlying economy
and present a fair and you know thorough
understanding of how the economy is
changing I I accept the point that there
there is a lot of seems like there's
more chatter today than there was a 10
or 20 years ago in terms of the just the
scale of talk whether it's on cable
networks or wherever about about any
kind of stress or problem the economy
spacing on the financial system color
has a has a point it's it's um the the
loans that happened especially in the
mortgage area there were a lot of bad
loans that said banks really are dealing
with that in the sense that there's been
something like a hundred billion dollars
in writedowns on on bank balance sheets
of banks saying and another financial
institution saying these loans we made
turns out there they're no good we don't
expect these people to be able to pay
off their their debts so we're going to
write this loan down and say that it's
not worth as much as we thought it did
so people are banks are taking a real
hit as a result of making some bad
decisions on Thursday you wrote under
the headline worried fed cuts key rate
again us growth stalled in fourth
quarter the Federal Reserve cut a key
interest rate yesterday for the second
time in just over a week as its leaders
concluded that the distress in financial
markets is a sufficient is a
sufficiently grave threat to ordinary
Americans to warrant the most aggressive
campaign of rate cuts in the modern
history of the central bank how much
seriously can these rate cuts have an
effect on stimulating the economy
there's there's two kinds of effects
there's the can
tional long-term impact on the economy
that takes 6 9 12 months to flow through
and that happens through making it
cheaper for businesses to borrow money
to expand makes it cheaper for consumers
to borrow money to you know buy a car
buy a house those those effects are very
ripple through the economy over a long
period of time part of what the Federal
Reserve is done in the last two weeks
with a combination of combined two cuts
for one and a quarter percent which is
as I say in the story unprecedent that
is that has really never happened in the
long as the as the fat has been
targeting the interest rate part of the
reason is to is to prevent a kind of
psychological dynamic from developing
where people think there's going to be a
severe downturn their worst nightmare is
for there to be the self-reinforcing
cycle that actually a previous caller
was was describing to some degree where
people are afraid of a severe recession
so they pull back on their spending that
businesses don't invest and that can
actually create a severe recession so
there's there's two effects and with
these very aggressive rate cuts the Fed
is trying to prevent that psychological
dynamic from taking hold and keep the
keep the economy and reasonably good
shape also on Friday payrolls drop for
the first time since 2003 this is an
article you wrote with Neil sorry with
Michael Abramowitz and if the viewers
want to go back and take a look at it
they can find it on washingtonpost.com
what is is there any evidence to suggest
that these payroll drops that this
situation that we're in with our economy
right now is just cyclical and that if
we just stay on the course that we're on
will eventually work our way out of it
and get back into the back into the the
plus side of the margin there are people
argued that that's not not a not a
ridiculous statement by any measure
there are some people who think that
once the immediate hit from the from the
housing problems and challenges in the
housing market pass and the financial
market problems that the economy is
poised to grow we're going to grow again
fairly quickly but it that said there
are a lot of indicators that we might be
in for something more challenging in the
economy there's again manufacturing
sectors turning down quite a lot the
pain and housing some people think it's
only just beginning
so that's uh that's a reason why
argument app Neil Irwin has been writing
for The Washington Post business section
since the year 2000 he's also covered
technology companies real estate
development and the Washington regional
economy back to the phones New Orleans
Louisiana you're on the Washington
journal good morning rewarding beg you
Percy sped up I had a question and a
comment the first question is is that
when we watch the news usually they do
the 530 Central News at night the people
who report on the economy will say well
the unemployment rate is five points
whatever percent without the kind of
caveat that you know in point employment
statistics aren't generally you know
used to earth tied to unemployment
benefits from the government why don't
they explain that because people assume
that there's only five point six percent
of population unemployed and my comment
is is that the first problem with this
moonshot is that the Ares rocket is
based on the Greek god of war I mean
during this time we've been legally
invaded a country I think gets a little
out of control to have that and another
thing the solution to this problem isn't
exactly going to the moon or not it's
the crowd the fact that the cost of
getting into orbit now is ten thousand
dollars a pound unless we get that down
lower and we're not going anywhere
thanks for your call you want to address
the first part of that sure the colors
correct the the unemployment rate is is
generated by a survey of american
households they call people up and ask
do the people in your house do they have
a job are they looking for a job that's
separate from the system of unemployment
insurance benefits so if you go to the
so if you're unemployed in the survey
you may or may not be actually getting
unemployment insurance benefits so
that's that's exactly right there there
is the the government does report how
many people have filed claims for
unemployment insurance benefits every
week and those numbers have been
creeping up so there's signs from that
set of data to that the economy
softening some next up is waterford
virginia go ahead yeah i'm trying to
find out are there any family income
parameters to what they call the middle
class every candidate out there talking
about the middle class does it go like
from 20 grand to 70 grand or where did
it go
the middle class and the second part of
the question is since its middle there
has to be something below it like a low
class if they would use that word but if
you have any parameters a middle class
and what do they call guide below the
middle class will be hidden Middle he's
got him in the middle of something
that's it middle classes in the eye of
the beholder I think if you asked a lot
of people how they would define middle
class room middle-income they would
define it differently I believe the the
median the kind of middle-income
American household is around makes
around 43 thousand dollars I believe now
in certain cities in New York or
Washington that wouldn't get you very
far that you know you might feel fairly
poor if you're if you're making 43
thousand dollars for a family in a city
like New York but but for the country at
large that that puts you in about the
middle of the income distribution and
our last call for Neil Irwin comes from
Hermitage Tennessee go ahead good
morning good morning I'm a small
business owner and consequently I've you
know it new businesses like mine
responsible for about eighty-two percent
you know of all the jobs in this country
not the major corporations like the
Democrats keep you know mongering on but
the thing that I have seen in my
business and the thing it is driving
everything including cost up is the
price of gas it's just that simple
Americans last year spent a hundred
forty four billion more dollars for the
same gallon of gas and that affects
everything in this economy we've got the
most incompetent idiotic Congress that
you could the money can possibly buy
because they pass an energy bill that
did not produce one single additional
drop of new domestic oil and that is
what is driving this economy down and it
is Congress and they will not get the
blame for the president well thank you
on on the price of gasoline that is
indeed a big drain on the economy that's
that's money that's going out of people
having to pay in the short run if the
price of gas goes up you it's hard to
drive much less you have your commute
set you have your car or
in place up so people just have to spend
more money it's kind of the equivalent
of a tax increase is the way some people
look at it you're just paying extra kind
of no matter what they're there I've
heard an argument that the that the
stimulus package is that both the house
and the senator debating right now that
those would essentially counteract the
negative impact on households of higher
gas prices so that's one way to think of
kind of a scale of those efforts what is
the current consumer confidence rate and
what does it say about the economy
consumer Commons been dropping its it's
down significant in the last three or
four months consumer confidence is a
tricky thing there are times when
consumer confidence Falls and it doesn't
really impact spending very much after
Hurricane Katrina for example consumer
confidence fell through the floor but
people kept spending money it didn't
seem to affect their buying patterns
there are some reasons to think that's
not the case this time that the the drop
in consumer confidence does have to do
with the people pulling back on their
spending because we see that in retail
sales numbers we see that and what the
big chain stores are saying about how
their year is going to be so their signs
that there's some real strains on the
American pocketbook right now and will a
change of the will the will the stimulus
package cause a significant change in
the consumer confidence rate or do
manufacturers have to start putting out
better products and service people start
offering better services well it's uh
it's it's hard to say do people will
receiving a 600 check or a 500 ll check
will that jog people's enthusiasm for
going to the store and buying things I
the evidence from from 2001 and 2003 is
kind of mixed some people as you
mentioned earlier just will put it in
the bank others will probably rush to
the store and buy whatever they've been
looking to get Neil Irwin thank you very
much for being on the program thanks Rob
in just a few minutes we're going to be
talking about the year-end fundraising
by the two thousand eight candidates
with Sheila krumholz we'll take a break
and we'll be right back